maybe another distinction we want to
try to get at is a difference between
fission and fusion
as you mentioned fusion is the kind of
reaction happening in the sun so what's
fission and what's fusion
well fission is taking heavy elements
like uranium
and breaking them up and it turns out
that that process of breaking up heavy
elements releases energy
what does it mean to be a heavy helmet
it means that there are many
nuclear particles in the nucleus itself
neutrons and protons in the
in the nucleus itself so that in the
case of
uranium there are 92 protons
in each nucleus and even more neutrons
so that
the total number of nucleons
in the nucleus nucleons is short for for
either a proton or a neutron
um the total number you know might be
235 that's
u235 or it might be 238
that's u238 so those are heavy elements
light elements by contrast have very few
nucleons protons or neutrons in the
nucleus
hydrogen is the lightest nucleus it has
one proton there are actually slightly
heavier forms
of hydrogen isotopes deuterium has
a proton and a neutron and tritium has a
proton
and two neutrons so it has total of
three nucleons in the new in the nucleus
well taking light elements
like isotopes of hydrogen and and not
breaking them up but actually
fusing them together reacting them
together to produce heavier elements
typically helium okay which is helium is
a nucleus which has
has two protons and two neutrons
that also releases energy and that and
that or reactions like that
making heavier elements from lighter
elements
is what mostly powers the sun and stars
both fusion and fission release
approximately a million times more
energy per unit mass than chemical
reactions
so a chemical reaction means take
hydrogen take
oxygen react them together let's say and
get
water that releases energy the energy
released in a chemical reaction like
that or the burning of coal or
on oil or whatever else is about a
million times less
per unit mass than what is released in
nuclear reactions
so but it's hard to do it requires
very high energy of impact
and actually it's very easy to
understand why and that is that
those two nuclei if they're both let's
say
hydrogen nuclei one is let's say
deuterium and the other is let's say
tritium
they're both electrically charged and so
that and they're positively charged so
they
they like charges repel everyone knows
that right
so basically to get them close enough
together to react
you have to overcome the repulsion the
electric repulsion
of the two nuclei from one another
and you have to get them extremely close
to one another in order for the nuclear
forces to overtake
the electrical forces and and actually
form a new nucleus
and so one requires very high energies
of
impact in order for reactions to take
place and those high energies of impact
correspond to very high temperatures
of random motion so that's why you can
do something like that
in the sun so we can build the sun
that's one way to do it
but on earth how do you create a fusion
reaction yeah well nature engineering
nature's fusion uh reactors are indeed
the stars
and uh they are very hot in the in the
center
and re and they reach the point where
they
release more energy from those reactions
than they lose by radiation and
transport to the surface and so forth
and that's
a state of ignition and
and that's what we have to achieve to to
give net energy it's like
lighting a fire if you if you have a if
you have a bundle of sticks and you hold
a match up to it
and you see smoke coming from the sticks
but you take the match away and the f
and the and the sticks just fizzle out
that's not
the reason they did it fizzled out is
that yes they were burning
there was smoke coming from them but
they were not ignited
but if you are able to take the match
away and they keep burning and they are
generating enough heat
to keep themselves hot and hence keep
the reactions going
that's chemical ignition well what we
need to do
what the stars do in order to generate
nuclear fusion energy is
they are ignited they are generated
enough energy to keep themselves hot
and that's what we've got to do on earth
if we're going to make fusion
work on earth but it's much harder to do
on earth than it is you know in a star
because you know we need temperatures
of order tens of millions of
degrees celsius in order for the
reactions to go
fast enough to generate enough
electricity to keep
or enough energy to keep it going and
and so um if you've got something that's
tens of millions of degrees
celsius and you want to keep it all
together and keep the heat in long
enough
to have enough reactions taking place
you can't just put it in a bottle
you know plastic or glass it would be
gone you know it's
in milliseconds um so
um you have to have some non-material
mechanism of confining the plasma
in the case of stars that non-material
force
is gravity so gravity is what holds a
star together it's what
holds the plasma in long enough for it
to react
and and and sustain itself by
the the fusion reactions but on earth
gravity is extremely weak i mean i don't
mean to say we don't fall
yes we fall but the the mutual
gravitational
attraction of small objects is very
weak compared with the electrical
repulsion or any other force that you
can think about
on earth and so we need a stronger force
to keep the plasma together to confine
it
and the predominant attempt
at making fusion work on earth is to use
magnetic fields
to confine the plasma and that's what
i've worked on for much
essentially most of my career is to
understand
how we can and how best we can confine
these incredibly hot gases plasmas using
magnetic fields
with the ultimate objective of releasing
fusion energy on earth
and you know generating electricity with
it and powering
our society with it uh dumb question
so on top of the magnetic fields do you
also need the plastic water bottle walls
or is it purely magnetic fields well
actually what we do need walls
um those walls must be kept away from
the plasma because otherwise they'd be
melted or the plasma must be kept away
from them
inside inside of them but the
main purpose of the walls is not to keep
the
plasma in it's to keep the atmosphere
out
so if we want to do it on earth where
there's air
um we want the plasma to consist of
hydrogen isotopes or other things the
things we're trying to react
and by the way the density
of those plasmas at least in magnetic
confinement fusion
is very low it's maybe a million times
less
than the density of air in this room
so in order for a fusion reactor like
that to work
you have to keep all of the air out and
just keep the plasma in so yes there are
other things
but those are things that are relatively
easy i mean making a vacuum
these days is technologically quite
quite straightforward we know how to do
that okay
what we don't quite know how to do is to
make a confinement
uh device that isolates the plasma
well enough so that it so that it's able
to keep itself burning with its own
reaction
so maybe can you talk about what a
takamaka is
the russian acronym from which the word
takamak is built just means toroidal
magnetic chamber
so it's a toroidal chamber taurus is a
is a
geometric shape which is like a doughnut
with a hole down the middle
okay and so it's the so it's the meat of
the doughnut
okay that's the taurus um and it's
and it's got a magnetic field so that's
really all takamak
uh means but the particular
configuration
um that we're the that is very
widespread and there's the
sort of best prospect in the least in
the near term for
making fusion energy work is one
in which there's a very strong magnetic
field
the the long way around the doughnut
around the taurus
um so you've got to imagine that there's
this doughnut shape
with an embedded magnetic field just
going round and round
the long way the the big advantage of
that
is that um plasma particles
are when they're in a in the presence of
a magnetic field
feel strong forces from the magnetic
field and those forces
make the particles gyrate around the
direction
of the magnetic field line so basically
the particles follow helical orbits like
like a following like a spring that's
directed along the magnetic field
well if you make the magnetic field go
in inside this toroidal chamber and just
simply go round and round the chamber
then because of this helical orbit
the particles can't move fast across the
magnetic field
but they can move very quickly along the
and if you have a magnetic field that
doesn't leave the chamber
it doesn't matter if they move along the
magnetic field it does
it means it doesn't mean they're going
to exit the chamber
but if you just had a straight magnetic
field as you you know for example
coming from um you know a helmholtz coil
or
or a bar magnet then you'd have to have
ends it would come would come to the end
ends of the chamber somewhere in the and
the particles would hit the ends and
and they would lose their energy so
that's why it's toroidal
and that's why we have a strong magnetic
field it it's
providing um a confinement against
motion
in the in the direction that would lead
the particles to leave the chamber
it turns out that then here we're
getting a little bit technical but it
turns out that
a toroidal field alone is not enough and
so you need more
fields to produce true true confinement
of
plasma and we get those by passing a
current as well
through the plasma itself i can make
sure it stays on track
well that what that does is makes the
field lines themselves into
much bigger helices and that
for reasons that are too complicated to
explain that
clinches the confinement of the
particles
at least in terms of their single
particle orbits so they don't leave the
chamber
so when the particles are flying along
this uh
this this donut the inside of the donut
uh are they what's where's the
generation of the energy coming from are
they smashing
into each other yeah eventually i mean
in a fusion reactor
there will be deuterons and triti and
tritons and they will be
smashing in they will be very hot
they'll be 100 million degrees
celsius or something so they're moving
thermally with very large thermal
energies
in random directions and they will
collide with one another
and have fusion reactions when those
fusion reactions take place
energy is released large amounts of
energy is released in the form of
particles
one of the particles that's released is
an alpha particle which is also charged
and it's also confined
and that alpha particle stays in the in
the in the doughnut and heats the other
particles that are in that doughnut
so it transfers its energy to those and
they it keeps them hot
there's there's some leaking of heat all
the time a little bit of radiation
some transport and so forth there's also
a neutron released from that reaction
the neutron carries out four-fifths of
the fusion energy
and that will have to be captured in a
blanket that surrounds
the chamber in which we
take the energy drive
some kind of electrical generator
from you know thermal engine
um gas turbine or something like that
and power the power you got energy
so where do we stand where do we stand
on
getting this thing to be something that
actually works it generates energy yep
well um there have been experiments that
have generated
net nuclear energies or nuclear powers
in the vicinity of
um you know a few tens of megawatts
for a few seconds so that's
you know 10 megajoules that's not much
energy
it's a few doughnuts worth of energy
okay yeah literal donut
literally that's right um
but um but we have studied how well
tokamax can confine plasmas and so we
now
understand in in rather great detail
um the way they work and we're able to
predict what is
going to be required in order to build a
tokamak that becomes self-sustaining
that becomes essentially ignited or very
so close to ignited that it doesn't
matter
and and at the moment at least if you
use
the modest magnetic field values
still very strong but but limited
limited magnetic field values
you have to build a very big device and
so we are at the moment
worldwide fusion research is
at the moment in the process of building
a very big experiment
that's located in the south of france
it's called eta
i-t-e-r which means the way or
just means the international tokamak
experimental reactor if you like
um and that experiment is designed to
reach this burning plasma state
and to generate about 500
megawatts of fusion power
for hundreds of seconds at a time it'll
still only be
an experiment it won't put electricity
on the grid or anything like that
it's it's to figure out what whether it
works and and with what the remaining
engineering challenges are it's a
scientific experiment
it won't be engineered to run round the
clock and
and so on and so forth which ultimately
one one needs to do
in order to make something that's
practical for generating electricity
but it will be the first demonstration
on earth
of a controlled fusion reaction reaction
for you know long time time period is
that exciting to you
yes uh it it it's been an objective that
is
in many ways motivated my entire career
and the career career of many people
like me in the field
i have to admit though that one of the
problems with eta
is that it's an extremely big and
expensive and
long time to build experiment and so it
won't even come into operation
until about 2025 even though it's been
being built for
10 years and it's been it was designed
for 30 years before that
right um and so that's actually one of
the big disappointments of my career
in a certain sense which is that we
won't get to
uh burning fusion uh reaction until well
past the first operation of eta
and whether i'm alive or not i don't
know um but i
certainly will be well and truly retired
by the time that happens
and so when i realized maybe some years
ago that that was going to be the case
it was a discouragement to me let's put
it like that
but if we can try to look maybe
in a ridiculous kind of way look into a
hundred years from now 200 years 500
years from now
and we you know there's folks like elon
musk uh
trying to travel outside the solar
system i mean
the amount of energy we need for some of
the exciting things we want to do
in this world if we look again 100 years
from now
seems to be a very large amount
so do you think fusion energy will
eventually
uh sometime into your retirement uh
will be basically uh behind
most of the things we do look i
absolutely think
that fusion research is completely
justified in fact we should be spending
more time and effort on it than we
currently do
but it isn't going to be a magic bullet
that somehow
uh solves all the problems of energy by
the way that's a generic statement you
could make about
any energy source in my view i think
it's a grave mistake to think that
science
of any sort is suddenly going to find a
magic bullet for meeting all the energy
needs of society or any of the other
needs of society by the way
but and we can talk about that by
hopefully later okay
um but but but but fusion is very
worthwhile and we should be doing it
um and and so my disappointment
that i just expressed um was in a
certain sense of personal disappointment
i do think that fusion energy is a
terrific challenge it's very difficult
to bring the energy source of the sun
and stars down to earth
this does contrast in a certain sense
with fission energy by contrast
fission energy efficient to build a
fission reactor proved to be amazingly
easy
you know we did it um within a few years
of discovering nuclear fission people
had
uh figured out how to build a reactor
and did so
um you know during the second world war
which is by the way
fission is how the current nuclear power
plants work yeah
and so we have uh nuclear energy today
because fission uh reactors are
relatively easy to build you've got to
have what's hard is getting
the materials okay and that's just as
well because if everyone could get those
materials you know there would be
weapons proliferation and so forth
but it wasn't um all that long
um after even the discovery of nuclear
fission that fission reactors were built
and fission reactors of course operated
before we had weapons
so i think
nuclear power is obviously
important to meet the energy challenges
of our age it is completely
intrinsically completely uh co2
emissions free
and in fact the wastes that come from
nuclear power whether it's fission or
fusion for that matter
are so moderate in quantity
that that we shouldn't really be worried
about them
um i mean yes fission products are
highly radioactive and
and we need to keep them away from
people but there's so little of them
it's that keeping them away from people
is not particularly difficult
and so while people complain a lot about
the drawbacks of fish and energy um
i think most of those complaints are
ill-informed
um we can talk about you know the the
challenges in the disasters if you like
of
uh of uh of fish and reactors but i
think
fission in the near term offers a
terrific opportunity
for environmentally friendly energy
which in which in the world as a whole
is rapidly being taken advantage of you
know china and india and places
like that are rapidly building fission
plants we're not rapidly building
fission plants
in the u.s although we are actually
building two at the moment
um two new ones um but we do still get
20 percent of our electricity from
fission energy and we could get a lot
more
so it's clean energy so it's clean
energy now
now again the concern is there's a very
popular
hbo show on uh just came out on
chernobyl
uh there's the three mile island there's
fukushima that's the most recent
disaster
so there's a kind of a concern of um
yeah i mean nuclear disasters
is that what do you make of that kind of
uh concern especially if we look into
the future of fission
energy based reactors well first of all
let me say one or two words about the
contrast between fission and fusion and
then we'll come on to the question of
the
disasters and so forth fission does have
some drawbacks and there
and they're largely to do with four
four main areas one is do we have enough
uranium
or other fissile fuels to to supply our
energy needs
for a long time the answer to that is we
know we have
um enough uranium to support fission
energy
worldwide for thousands of years
but maybe not for millions of years okay
so that's resources um secondly
there there are issues to do with wastes
fission wastes
are highly radioactive and some of them
are volatile
and so for example um in
fukushima the the problem was
that some fraction of the fission waste
were volatilized
and went out as a cloud and and polluted
air areas with um cesium
137 the strontium 90 and things like
that
so that's a challenge of fission um
there's a problem
of safety uh beyond that
and that is that um in fission
it's hard to turn the reactor off when
you turn when you stop the nuclear
reactions
there is still a lot of heat being
liberated from the fission products
and that is actually what the problem
was at fukushima
the fukushima reactors were shut down
the moment that the earthquake took
place
and they were shut down safely what then
happened after that
fukushima was you know there were there
was this enormous
tidal wave um many tens of meters high
that came through
and destroyed the electricity
grid feed to the fukushima reactors and
their
cooling was then turned off and it was
the after heat
of the turned off reactors that
eventually caused the problems that
led to release and so that so that is
that's a safety concern and then and
then
finally there's a problem of
proliferation
and that is that fission reactors need
fissile fuel
and the technologies for producing the
under
enriching and so forth the fuels can be
used
can be can be um by by bad actors
to generate um the materials needed for
a nuclear weapon and that's a very
very serious concern so those are the
four problems
fusion has major advantages in respect
of
all of those problems it has more uh
longer term um fuel resources
it has far more benign waste
issues the react the radioactivity from
fusion reactions is at least a hundred
times less than it is from fission
reactions
it has um no none essentially none of
this
after heat problem because it doesn't
produce fission products that are
highly radioactive and generating their
own heat
when it's turned off in fact the hard
part of fusion is turning it on not
turning it off
and and finally you don't need the same
uh
fission technology to do to make fusion
work and so
it there it's got terrific advantages
from the point of view of proliferation
control
so those are the those are four main
issues which make fusion seem attractive
technologically
because they address some of the
problems of fish and energy
i don't mean to say that fission energy
is overwhelmingly problematic
but clearly there have been catastrophes
associated with fission reactors
fukushima actually is i think in many
ways
often overstated as a disaster because
after all
nobody was killed by the reactors
essentially
zero and that's in the context of
a disaster a tsunami that killed between
and 20 000 people instantaneous more or
less instantaneously
so you know in the scale of risks
um one should take the view that
uh in my in my in my estimation that
um fish and energy came out of that
looking pretty good
okay of course that's not the popular
conception okay
yes it's gonna i mean with a lot of
things that threaten our well-being
we seem to be very uh bad
uh users of data we seem to be very
scared of uh
shark attacks and not at all scared of
car accidents and
this kind of miscalculation and i think
from everything and i understand uh
nuclear energy efficient based energy
goes into that category
it's one of the safest one of the
cleanest forms of energy
and yet the pr uh
whoever does the pr for nuclear energy
is not uh
has a hard job ahead of them at the
moment well i think part of that is
their association with nuclear weapons
right because when you say the word
nuclear people don't instantly think
about nuclear energy they think about
nuclear weapons
and and so there is you know perhaps um
a natural tendency to do that but yes i
agree with you people are very poor
at estimating risks and they react
emotionally not rationally in most of
these situations
you